I didn't know what futsal was like
because we're a machine it's like the
indoor like kind of like yeah like the
street ball version of soccer exactly
like Nike has like their facility area
Mandy that has its hazards yeah so I
think adidas only has like 9 or 10 in
the world and we have one here in like
near downtown yeah so we needed it and
it's cool I just painted it look at him
just fit I just I just paint it's cool
it's whatever like so that's want to see
this I'm saying like I have I love that
[ __ ] though man like you you kind of
like create I like having art that I
respect a lot right so it's like yeah I
know a lot of art where I see that no
that's cool but I don't have a want to
buy it cuz I would have walked by it and
I wouldn't have a connection with it you
know something that I like seeing yeah
you know what I mean so it's it's that's
what people like I even asked some my
friends like they're not like really
well-known artists and that great I'm
just doing for fun I was like you know
if you paint something for me I'll put
it up just because I like you as a
person and if there's a connection to it
mm-hmm
because art does have this weird thing
where I feel like it's and I think this
is why I don't know how people feel
about Street I like street art because
it's just art for what art is it's not
some rich holy xx person saying like
this is worth a million dollars so I'm
telling you it's worth a million dollars
like I could look at and say that's
[ __ ] dope yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] the hype
yeah yeah yeah I would never want to buy
something because of the hype yeah you
know look at me I'm [ __ ] I went into
a I went into the [ __ ] Road you're
like the broad museum yeah there was a
[ __ ] painting worth like [ __ ] like
three million dollars mm-hm and it was
the I'm sorry not a painting it was
chalk art and the guy just drew a line
of dicks I did that in the fourth grade
[Laughter]
there was somebody else who put up a
wall and it was just like two plus two
equals four and they were scratching all
this like random mathematic equations
I'm like bro every Asian little kid
should be on in here then are you
[ __ ] kidding me
and it was worth like ten million
dollars I will [ __ ] stab you in the
eye and that was just a bunch of rich
people that got together and said yo
that's some next-level [ __ ] and then
they they made it ten million dollars
yeah I mean I could talk a lot of [ __ ]
about the art world like I don't want to
but it's literally controlled by the top
tier people yeah like the top I don't
know there's a couple round yeah three
or four and auction houses and they kind
of set the thing yeah and everybody else
we're just kind of like fighting for
scraps or whatever yeah that's what I
like murals yeah like I mean I'm not a
[ __ ] I'll be stuff too but like I've
been just doing murals and yeah it's
just a little too like I don't know what
would you call it snobby you know what
like paying millions I'm not gonna kiss
an ass yeah I mean like you are not good
yeah I would I would die in Hollywood
yeah does not kiss one I've never seen
him kids like what as the way I'm
talking to you guys is the way I talk to
like a CEO and that's how I should tell
like my friends to like church pastor
you know I like the accessibility of
street art maybe that's what I like so
much about it right anybody can look at
it and appreciate it mm-hmm you don't
have to be an art major to say that's
dope you don't have to be like oh did
you know that this empty that this white
canvas is supposed to represent the
emptiness of the spirits of people in LA
get the [ __ ] out of my face with that
[ __ ] dude and like Instagram has or this
whole social platform has created the
accessibility for artists yeah and like
street art realm or whatever our realm
yeah you see them you follow them you
can buy their ship by hitting them up
basically on a text message yeah which
like which I think would probably mean a
lot more to a collector or or a fan way
more than just that kind of idea like
someone telling you this is what it's
about and then you spend your whole
check on some I don't know the [ __ ] that
cracks me up the most is one when I went
to the broad I actually recorded my
something you're supposed to record
yourself
just like clowning on people I saw this
girl stand in front of that dick mural
right
and she just was sitting there with an
arm cross with her hand on her chin then
she goes yes yes yes what yes what
what's she trying to suck them deep and
then her boyfriend is like indulging her
or whatever the date that she's on he
goes yeah I could see yeah I meant like
this is [ __ ] some next-level [ __ ]
like I I wanted a Tonya Harding [ __ ]
[ __ ] lead-pipe me captain
and I just like you're literally feeding
into your own [ __ ] man it's okay for
you to say I don't know what the [ __ ]
I'm looking at it's okay yeah that
speaks to the power [ __ ] man yeah